[Music]
Hello, welcome to Chat on Aren, your
weekly podcast where we recommend and
exchange ideas about content we've
read, listened to, and watched, always bringing the
perspective of product PR discussion. I'm
Artur, and
this week I'm feeling cold, man. Today it's
a little chilly,
not super cold, it's really cold, man.
Today I went to
work by bike, and I had to stop at one point
and kind of turn my jacket into
gloves, you know? Wow, I went to buy bread this
morning, and I was like in flip-flops, pants, and a jacket, so
my
unprotected parts of my body suffered like that.
And in today's program, we're
going to talk about the following topics: the
present and future of AI products, and the
relationship between AI and Excel.
And also, we're going to talk about a
topic that was controversial a long time
ago but still continues to be, right?
There's a world beyond
Spotify squads. Oh, good topics today, huh?
But before we get into it,
today... no, my dear Watson.  Okay, just a
reminder: on
August 24th, we have the fifth edition of the
critical and analytical thinking course with
Dudu Magalhães. So, if you have any doubts
about how to connect the things
you do in your product with
financial indicators, come and join us! We'll be
talking about this all day, so you
'll leave knowing how to do
impact analysis to show that a
button flip can generate a ton of
money, right? It's tough,
but at the very least, you'll learn how to
do basic math, which we
talk about all the time in our episodes, and in one
episode,
Alice talks a lot about
her basic math. Also, on
September 14th, next month,
we'll have the fourth edition of the AI
for PMs in Practice course, which is a topic
we always talk about here. So,
if you want to learn the behind-the-
scenes of creating products with AI, what it is,
how to use AI in your daily life to make
your day easier, including our
Ikira here, will be there.  He's also talking about
how he created GPT to make
his life easier when mapping events, so that
's it. Contextualized plug,
detailed plug, and the sneaky discount
that only listeners get is here in the description
with 15% off, huh? Look at that! Big discount!
Now let's get to the agenda. Let's go!
[Music]
Okay, we're going to start
today's program, it's not exactly with a
specific topic, actually it's become a mix of
content that made us bring up this
presumptuous topic, right? To say what the
future of the show is in this program. Today,
Artur, we're going to make a decision and
predict the future. Obviously, we're
going to be wrong, but that's okay. It's like at the beginning
of the year we did the episode "The
Predictions Nobody Asked For," right? So,
we have to go back to the end of the year
to see what we got
wrong, what we got right. The last
program of the year will be this, it will be the
recap of what we got wrong and what we got right.
But let's continue here, right? The
main content that inspired this topic was a
text by...  Benedict Evans called them
Summer. But there are several other references
that we'll leave in the
comments, including those that talk about
AI and Excel, as Artur said, which we'll
bring up in a moment. Those who have been listening to the podcast for a
while will notice that
we continue to bring news, and
we have been bringing it quite
frequently in recent programs, right? But
there's much less product and
exciting news than in the beginning. I don't know if
you have the same feeling, Artur, but
I feel that in the beginning it seemed like every
week there was something really cool, and it's not
like there isn't now. Like, there's
Flux now, which is the new image model
that's generating super realistic,
super good images, and so on. But there's this feeling
that things are evolving but not
taking big leaps like before. And
this TR... the really cool points are where
we are... and in this wave of... hey,
where we might be going... and to
begin, I think the data that pulls
me into a discussion that I find very
interesting, which he presents in the text,
is that at least 25 to 30% of people
in developed countries have already used
GPT chat specifically, and that's the glass
halfway point.  It's full of data, right? If you think about it,
a product launched 18 months
later, 1/3 of the population, 20% of the population,
had already used it. And then came the glass half
empty: only around 10% of the people
who know about it use it weekly, and use
can be anything here, right? There's no
discrimination there about what I
use. And another cool idea that comes from this
text is that the products kind of
skipped the traditional adoption curve,
right? That famous S-curve that's in
a lot of product reviews, and they
had great awareness initially,
but they didn't go through that phase of
discovering product-market fit, right?
Starting small in a niche with
adopters, discovering fit, and
scaling. Like, it kind of
scaled, it kind of scaled to the point where everyone
knows it, a lot of people have heard of it,
and now we're kind of thinking, right?
So I've already said a lot here, I'll open it up
for you to bring your comments, and then
we'll talk more about it later. Well,
Benedict Evans,
his news, the content is always
very good, right? I've been following him for a long time, he's one
of the guys I highly recommend.
So, and I really like that he always
brings good analogies and
comparisons, right? That's because, you know, the guy's been around for a long time,
doing
market analysis, man. For me,
he's the guy from the strategist, but
summarized like this: "But man, I think
some of the data he brought that are
relevant is this: It took more than 20
years for 20% of US retailers
to be online, right? And it was
even that thing with that curve that
went past the trend line during the
pandemic and then went back to the
trend line, right? Exactly, we're only talking
about 20% of establishments, you know? Damn, man,
1/5, you know? We're
chronically online, like, I thought
everything was online, right? Exactly, but it's not real."
Another thing he talks about, right, about
Apple and the first iPhone, right?
It took, man, the first version, the
first 12 months, it only sold 5 million
devices, uh, in the first 12 months, and
today, man, there was no App Store, man, there was no App Store,
in fact, it wasn't even in the plans
for an App Store because they believed
everything was online.  Right, exactly. So, these
things don't always come at the speed
we want, man. I know we're
digital natives, and we're always on the
dopamine side, wanting everything
yesterday. When we access
things online, we don't know, we just Google it and we already
have the answer, we think that
works for everything, right? And I
think that's the case, I think mainly the case.
But it's the
first thing we're seeing on a
large scale, you know, in our
generation, I think, like, I don't know, the
iPhone. When we became
adults, I was still a teenager, and
then when we became adults, well,
we know that the iPhone sells like
crazy, and so on. So it's
always been like that, and no, it hasn't been, right? I'll
even give a shout-out here
to Johnny, who talks about the
Mandela Effect, remember? It's true, it's
true. So I think this thing
is kind of the Mandela Effect, like, wow, okay,
now everyone
uses it, everyone knows it works, all
the companies that use it, it's going to be on everyone's
lips and in everyone's hands.  Right,
exactly. It's crazy, isn't it?
Because, in fact, we
are chronically online people,
we're on Twitter, we're very
early adopters of things and we test them, like, "Oh,
you see it in your whole bubble, everywhere
you consume news, that's all anyone talks about,"
so it's very easy to get into this
echo chamber here, which isn't a
negative echo chamber of "everyone
knows what this is,
everyone's using it," and no, it's quite the
opposite. There are quite a few
people who have an idea of ​​what it is or
vaguely know it, but actually using it is
rare. This is when we talk about
individuals, when we talk about
legal entities, like companies. The
text also mentions that there's research showing
that companies are
planning to deploy things by
2026. So, you might say, "
No, but there are a lot of companies
using it, I've seen a lot of texts about it,"
but how many of these use cases are
complete workflow replacements and
not tests? Because
there are a lot of people doing tests, even
earning money, just to
do tests.  For a lot of
companies, but how many companies will take on the challenge? "
I'm going to replace this
entire workflow that was done by humans or
other systems with real ones," you
know? So, deploying this in the
corporate environment takes much longer, right? That's it,
and that's it. Okay, companies can
take advantage of others that
are faster and hire
them, right? That's the case with Docket.
We have very large enterprise clients,
but if they were to create a
structure there, use technology to
optimize some part of
their process, it would take a very long time. So they
use Docket, which is something we already
use. We already use a lot of things, they're in a
short time, which is a bit of what
we've seen too, right?
Companies are buying other
companies that have this piece of the puzzle.
Hotmart did that too. Our clients are
much more
traditional clients, right? Banks and such,
financial institutions. At Hotmart, which is not what
we do, one way to
accelerate the creation of things was to buy
other companies that already
had this expertise, a launched product,
and so on. Anyway, I think another thing
he talks about a lot there is that...  Two
articles discuss quite a bit on day two,
which is that LLM itself isn't a product,
right? And that's it. How does that become
more visible to the user? The flow there has
all the X parts, how does that make
it so that people actually use it? As
we've already discussed in several
episodes, like, each update
of ChatPT kills 20 or 30 startups that it
itself created, right? It even gave space for them to
be created. But what is that?
And then the other article says that it
's like Excel, right? You're easy
to use, but that doesn't mean it's
easy to start using. That's very good,
but the interface isn't always the
best. So it could be that
Excel is behind it, which we've seen
millions of companies
use Excel to
organize things, and nowadays, that's
no longer the case. And
the same thing, we've seen many
things that ultimately run
behind it, it's ChatPT, or the cloud, or
something else. In Ever's article,
he says, "Look, we launch something
that behind it is..."  In the cloud, you can
open the cloud and ask it a question, and
it will give you the answer.
But that's it. Not everyone wants to do
that. I'll even give an example
in the context of Docked. We were
wanting to launch a product, and we
launched a product for reading
any type of document. We
have our specialized documents.
And then we went there and made one for
generic reading, to interpret
any type of document, just like that.
But the very simple version. I
could simply put, "Hey,
ask here, the text is open, and
ask here, what is it?" But
again, our clients are enterprise and
all that. What we did was, "No,
I'm going to guide the user." So, like this: "Look
here, write what field
you want instead of asking for a type,
writing a bunch of things, just tell me the
field." And then behind the scenes, we do a whole
process and everything else. But the user did
n't need all that, you know?
So I think that fits into this, that's
how we make these
adaptations. And that's it. The more we
understand the product, the more we understand the pain. Neither the
product nor the pain of the user understands the pain of the user.
The name you
want to give the user, the client's name, will be easier to use for
guiding or instructing the
user, whether it's in the interface,
instructions, or whatever. I really
like this comparison with Excel
because Excel is the greatest software
ever invented in the world, right?
You can do anything in
Excel; it's practical. And as you said, it
's very basic to start using,
and it can become very
complex. And what many of these texts
say is that every time you have a
spreadsheet that someone
maintains or that has a series of
automations running in it, it
basically becomes a BB-
size, right? And if you think about it, a good part
of the SS that have become large, that have
emerged in recent years or even
older, like a CRM, a SI
Force, or something like that—obviously, I'm
simplifying a lot here—but a
lot of contact records and
notes about those contacts, right? So
a CRM is that, what is SI
if not something you could do in
Excel? You could control your
sprints, your tasks, do the study,
whatever, all in Excel.  He went there
and said, "Damn, I don't want to do this
in Excel, I need
specialized software for this, so he can
go deeper into this use case, this
pain point." And I can see a lot of that being... you
know, the first interface
we were exposed to is a
very simple interface, a chat box
where you type and interact. Just like when
you open Excel, you have cells,
rows, and columns that are very simple
to act on, but as you go
deeper, you can create
extremely complex things, entire systems,
automations. And then software will emerge
that is built on top of that. So what
was, I don't know, last summer,
being an "ai rapper" was an insult. I
think, in reality, being an "ai rapper" is being
a B2B size from the 2020s, which is what we're in
now, you know? Maybe. So I can
imagine a world where there's a
person who maintains a
specific GPT that has some automations
running on it, nobody knows... Damn, this
has the potential to become a
separate software, and that's a big thing in itself, you
know? I like to call this
the cost of convenience, right? It's
exactly that, there will always be...  Someone
willing to pay for something
they don't want to learn, something
they want to use, something to do, but
they don't want to have to do it. Sometimes it's
something that's only marginally a little
better, you know? A good part of the websites
we use every day are like that. It's not that it ca
n't be done another way, it
's marginally better than the other. Like,
using a Trigger over a
Gira, that's a big deal, it
's not marginally better, but there are companies
that pay millions of dollars for that
marginally better thing, you know?
[Music]
This is today's second piece of content, a
presentation given by Nan Iu, I think that's
the way to say it, who is the head of
product at Liner. We were talking about
Gira, right? Liner is a competitor of
Gira, it's quite famous in Silicon Valley,
and it was a talk he gave at the Config
event for Figma that we talked about in a
recent episode. There's an episode
talking about it. So look it up in your
feed, the name of the talk is "The Hair Loon
Tomato Org Shart," which is a very
strange name to address the central idea that the way things are done...
Companies
organize themselves, and it directly reflects on the
product delivered to the user.
Many companies end up optimizing to
have a pretty,
traditional, trendy team topology instead of optimizing
for what they actually want to deliver to the customer.
And that's the Herlon tomato analogy. I do
n't know if you've seen it, Artur, but the Herlon
tomato is apparently a type of
tomato that's very tasty. He
says that companies optimize to
have a pretty, round tomato
instead of this one. It's very tasty, but it
's kind of strange; it looks like a tangerine.
So that's the analogy here. And
to further the discussion, what I
found interesting, especially
considering that we have many people
listening to the program who are at an
advanced stage of their careers, is that we
should be very intentional and discuss
the organization of
product and technology teams extensively. Don't just
copy the F-squad model, the
Spotify model, but I think one
thing that hinders this, and what
most people have had
little experience with other types of
company organizations, is that we always talk about the
product cycle, the
toolkit, and how you need to
gain experience to move through it.
Different product experiences
enrich your skillset, and sometimes
you'll go through many different companies and
product cycles within the same
type of company topology, right? That wo
n't give you that
knowledge or that critical perspective, and then
you'll end up relying on literature and
very similar experiences
you've already had. And I ask you, my
dear Artur, have you ever reached the point of
being an enemy of the squads? Because sometimes
I feel like that, sometimes I say, "Wow, I'm tired,
tired of this
organization, and
you arrive wanting to demolish the squads
already!" Man,
demolish the squads? No, but again,
as we always say here, there's
no magic formula. In
practice, theory is very different, you know? The
most PM-like answer possible,
right? It depends, the famous "it depends"? No, it
's even less "it depends." It's just that, in the end, that's
it. In practice, it's very
different, you know? Because, "Oh,
why do you have to have teams that
do this and that, and you
have to have multidisciplinary teams,
blah blah blah," but that's it, and then you
go there.  Okay, so there's a team that takes care of
a part, but any team can do
deployment, right? Then you go to the team that takes
care of a part and they'll have to constantly
stop to look at each other's code.
So, it's not like everyone
can mess with this thing anymore,
because that's it. Does it make
sense to leave it in one
context or another? So,
the whole team needs
a designer, needs a planner, needs a developer,
needs a
PR team. You have to put that
nice little box where all the
teams have the same format with the
same disciplines, right? And it's not. And
something he talks about a lot is
having cap size and scope, right? And that's it,
the more you
understand this, not every team
will need to have all the
disciplines in the docket. I have teams that
don't have design, uh-huh, I have other teams that do, some teams
have machine
learning, other teams don't, and so it is, and it's not,
oh,
we have to have two back-end developers, two front-end developers,
two developers, I don't know...  Well, no, man, each one
will depend, but before you get to
that part, okay? What are the people,
what are the disciplines that we
need on this team? And I think that
after that, we'll get to what skills we
need from the people on this team, a step
back, that's it, you understand? Okay, what
is the scope that we will have for each
team, or what are the scopes that we
want to address, to know which teams
you can or cannot have? And then you'll
say, okay, what is the format that I
will have for each of these teams? You
'll get to, okay, what is the profile
of the people I need for this
team? Man, I think even before that, right?
What's important to your company
or not, right? Like, really,
not everything has the same degree of
importance. I remember a long
time ago, back when we were at the time, there was
a moment when we literally
discontinued the Pivot team
to focus on another area. Not that the
area they were working on was
important; we were working on
engagement, and we went to
focus on another area that was more
important, just because at that
moment it made more sense for the company to
attack one part rather than the other.
So I think that's it, the more we
discover this and the more we
say that it's not just
literature, it's not just putting up a little
video and seeing that it will
work, you're testing
different things, right? And one of the things I've
always really liked, and one of the reasons
we created Prod Carena and everything
else, is that. Okay, how are
other companies doing it?
You say, okay, but tell me why
you're doing it this way?
Because here the context is x, y, z. I remember
when we decided to break down and change the
structure of...  From IUSE, because when
we started, as I've mentioned in some other
episodes here, we used to structure things
by product, by type of insurance, and we
had a mobile squad. Then, a
year later, we said, "Hey, I don't know, I
think we're finding
some things here that maybe we
have other points now where maybe
this structure doesn't work anymore." Uh-huh, and
then I talked to the people at
Booking.com, I was with a bunch of
people
from Spotify too. I talked to a
bunch of other companies here in
Brazil, and each one had a different format
to solve the problem, and it was very much like, "This
is our format here
because we want to solve x, y, z." So
we opted for this great format, and
then we went back home and said, "Okay," and
even sent a shout-out to Loren
here. We sat down and exchanged ideas,
saying, "Okay, what's the format
we want? What do we want to
solve? What are the new
challenges we have now?" Okay,
so for these challenges, maybe the
structure doesn't make sense anymore. Okay,
so let's go.  Let's see how that's going to be,
right? Before, we had a
team that
concentrated all the
mobile devs (Android, iOS, etc.). When we
did that, we broke that up; we no
longer had Square, we ended the SAD
Mobile division, and it was broken down into
teams with disciplines in each one.
So the structure of the squads
also changed because of that; there were squads that didn't even
have mobile. So I think
bringing it back here, right? This is
n't a "One Size Fits All" situation. In the end, the
more you know what
problems you're going to solve, the more
you'll see what structure
you'll have. I think that's the
important thing: intentionality.
When assembling the teams, you understand what
you're optimizing for, what
you want to achieve with it. What is the
objective? This mentions US, and I
also remembered the discussion we had at
Pier, which was very similar when Pier
started only with cell phone insurance.
So we were divided by journeys:
acquisition journey,
customer experience journey,
claims journey. And then the moment came when...
We were creating another product, which was
car insurance, and then we had this
discussion about whether we should go for
a product-based format
or maintain the
journey-based format. We were being
very intentional in the discussion about what a
product-based format means. You can
specialize much more, you can
deliver a much more tailor-
made product for that context.
The tradeoff here is that if you start
separating the two products,
the experiences will most likely start to
make no sense. So when people
talk about splitting the
organizational structure of your company, it's that
kind of thing. If you're divided
by product, for example,
you'll most likely start to have
products that go in
different directions, and eventually you'll start
to have inconsistencies because it's
difficult to maintain consistency. At the time,
we even made a decision to
stay product-based for a while and then return
to the journey-based format, largely because of this, to
maintain consistency. Like, you need
someone looking at the
acquisition journey of both products because
we want to be a multi-product company.
So it makes sense to consider the
acquisition journey of both.  Or any products that
may come out in the future about this, I
think that's really, really cool. And
this thing about you having a lot of
clarity about what the main thing
your company does is and what
necessarily needs more resources, right?
And sometimes you put more people there
or have more vacancies there even if you don't
need them because that's where you'll eventually
need them, where you'll get more feedback to
iterate on, more problems
happening, right? And that's okay. If there are
other teams that are less well-served
there, and damn, there are several cool things
he talks about in this video that I've already seen,
like, "Oh, there's that team that
clearly takes care of something less
important, but it has the
same structure as the team that takes care of the most
important thing." And then everyone who joins
joins that team to learn, but they end up
learning about the least
important thing in the company instead of going
to a relevant business. And there's the famous,
damn, so we need to add the
KR, right? So we need to... We need the
goal system here to solve this, right?
My God, I wrote this part down
because, damn it, man... This is
my
eternal, eternal, eternal discussion, eternal fight,
man, that's it. People think that's...
This, putting the KR (OKR) will now make
everyone
from
OKR... and... I think we can do
an episode later, just talking about
myths, myths about
OKRs, just giving feedback on
OKRs... but that's it... and another cool thing
he talks about is, where do
these things come from, and why do we follow them?
So, there's the two-box pizza, TIM
from Amazon, the squads from Spotify, High
Output Management, which he
even mentions in the video... it's a book
from '83 by a guy who was CEO of Intel, and
we apply things today as if we
were still in 1983, right? Not
adapted to today's GJ (Good Management). I'm not saying
here that Royal Output Management doesn't have
good things, but there are things that need to
be adapted to your time, and
obviously you gain knowledge
of things to think about what's
best for your context, not just take it from
one place and apply it. The example he gave
there... it was made at a time when there
wasn't even proper internet, there wasn't
Slack, WhatsApp, etc. If it were a
company that...  "He was making chips, right? Another
thing, so that's it. I find it funny
that he swapped Grove for
Nvidia's CE. Grove had like One One with
all the reports directly, Nvidia's CE has 40
reports
directly, [ __ ] it. Yeah, I think that's a
big, big thing. Like, the truth is there's
no right structure, right? I think there's
what will work for the
moment you're in. And I think that's what
you said you did, right? And
I think it's always worth talking
to people, like, find someone who's
already been through a similar company stage,
your company is facing a similar challenge,
and get references. Because
everyone who's ever done something has messed up at some point
in life. If you've done
something in your life, you most likely messed up. It's
no different at work. We
learn from our mistakes, so if you
can learn from other people's mistakes,
the person will say, 'Damn, don't do that,'
or even, 'Damn, do this, but be
careful with this, this thing here, it
could go wrong.' And once again, I think it's
worth mentioning an aspect you mentioned
about the, the, the..."  The
intentional aspect, and quoting
Alice again when she was
talking about structure, when we
exchanged ideas, she said, "The
only certainty is that we're
not going to
solve all the problems, but the
more intentional you are, the more you
'll know which problems you
need to solve at that moment. There may
be some that fall through, you won't
solve them, and that's okay, but what's agreed upon is
n't expensive, right?" So everyone is
aware that, "Hey guys, we have this problem,
yes we do. Are we going to solve it?" So everyone is asking, "
Why? Because this other
problem here is
much more important to solve than this one."
So let's go, exactly, exactly, and you don't need to
die clinging to your structure, right?
It can and should change as the company
changes, as the world changes. So, just
because you chose a certain way doesn't mean
you have to cling to it until the
end of your life, exactly, man. And I think...
This is one of the things that... There's
another analogy that's often talked about, right? That
every company is an organism, right? And that's it, man,
every structure is
susceptible to change and depends a lot on
how the market is doing.  Sometimes it's the
market and your business specifically,
right? Sometimes it's like this, man,
we're in a recession, so
you'll probably have to streamline and
do more with less. We're in a period
of plenty, so we'll have more
structures here, more teams, more bets,
more points to make, anyway, it
depends a lot, and that's it, you'll have to
do this tuning accordingly.
So, damn, there's a huge problem
here now, there's going to be some new legislation,
damn, we have to do this and that, okay?
Or, man, let's close a
million-dollar partnership with some
company. So, man, we need to focus
on this, get so-and-so, so-and-so, and so-and-so
here for a team to do the
Avengers here to solve it, you know? And that
's it, theoretically, the Avengers won't make
sense anymore, you know? And okay, it's
funny, like, the company
really just changes its address, because of
the different
situations, the CNPJ, everything, even the analogies. I'll
take the Avengers here, analogies of our
time clearly, right? Because in the past it
should have been others, like the Power
Rangers or the old Ultra, the Super
Friends, that's it, okay? We're already
daydreaming...  Wow, this episode is
messed up
[Music] you know,
speaking of which, it doesn't have any
connection, but I was going to say we should go to the
products of the week, let's go, my
product of the week, I'll start here, no, I'll start here,
but man, I'm
using... I started using a recent app and
my experience with it has been very good, that's why
I'm going to say it's the
Lite, I don't even know if that's how you say it, but that's what
I'm thinking, it's Lite, it's the one
that has the health scale,
tracks, that, that, and so, man, I
started using it recently, but I'm
having a
very good experience, I'll explain it to the
people who don't know what
Lite is. Man, I don't know if I'll
explain it very well, but basically,
do your best, go ahead, okay, I'll do my best, let's go,
but basically, it's an app that you
have, right, there's an app too, right, but it
's a company that has you, you have a
nutritionist, you have a psychologist, and
other things here to do your
follow-up there, and they
give you a scale for you to
do the...  Bipedance and so on, and you have
these more routine check-ups every
x days on the scale, but then you don't
need to go anywhere, right? It's all online, so
the recipes, tips, and
things like that, with online consultations, makes
tracking easier. So,
you track everything in the app, etc.
So, I'll be bringing more updates. I'll
leave my link here in the comments
for anyone who wants to try it and get a 50%
discount. They're not sponsoring this, damn it, it
could be a sponsorship, damn it!
But I'll leave it there for anyone who wants to try it in
the next episodes. The app
works well, man, isolated searches, like
you answer the questions,
super practical, and anyway, that's it, cool. I
met Fernando, who is one of the
co-founders of Caraca, so send a
hug to him, a hug there! And it really is
a super cool idea, it's great
that you're... You're enjoying it, you're afraid
of dying, right?
Now that you're going to be a dad, you're taking care of yourself,
right? Well, I've been taking care of myself for
a while, but now I'm taking even better care of myself,
but I love testing this
stuff, so cool.  That's
it, and yours, man, mine is the
opposite of healthy, right? Mine is the
wine subscription club app, the one that's
cold in BH, you know?
And then, me and my wife
got into the wine drinking thing, and
the truth is, neither of us knows
anything about wine, so we
decided to subscribe to a wine club here, where
we receive two... okay, which one did
you subscribe to? I subscribe too,
let me see which one I subscribed to... I
subscribed to the Wine Club. No, but
which type, which is the essential one,
the basic one, because we don't know anything, so we
said, "Ah, let's go with this one,
we'll learn, we'll see what
we like and so on," and then, man, the
box arrived, awesome! The app
is also very cool, everything has the
content of the magazine in the app, there's an
explanation of each wine, so for someone like me who
is a complete zero in
wine knowledge, I think it's
a good thing if you want to learn, and it
's not expensive, so it's super easy to subscribe.
And then, learning more, very good, mine is...  Well,
when I started... I've been a
student for a long time, and when I
started subscribing to mine, it was also in that
wave. I subscribe to the Wine Box,
refreshing white wine, you know, things like that.
Because I prefer my childish palate, I
like things that are sweeter,
etc. There are some wines that leave your throat
drier than wet, and I
thought, "No, it's not fair enough." I'll figure it out later,
I think I haven't
discovered yet what I
actually like. Maybe in a few months, that'll be good. And
what did people send us? Today, a
lot of people sent things, even though
we still send things at the last minute, right? As
always, but Cloves...
Look, Cloves sent from Figma Lives.
He said, "For those who make prototypes
in Figma, etc., to put together the
presentation, it's like pure
Integration juice." Look, there's the reference
we talked about in one of our
podcast episodes with Len and
Mirica Capur, who was the PM behind
Figma Slides. So, and we also talked about
the Figma conference,
exactly, everything is referenced.  Well, yeah, as
Steve Jobs would say, nothing is created,
everything is transformed. Here's
the week's highlights
from the crew: Danira talked about the insurance company,
how his car broke down, and he
quickly
resolved it using the app;
Glauco talked about the Nespresso app,
that thing doesn't affect me anymore,
now I'm... well, a coffee maker, but you don't
drink coffee, I drink
coffee, but now I make my own coffee,
my Espresso machine, blah blah blah. Oh, I
'll tell you about a Zinha capsule to
have after lunch, for
convenience, I like to
make it in the morning, but after lunch... Karina
sent a picture of Nock Knx, which is
her condo's app, I even
asked her if there are
condo dramas because, you know,
condo groups always have drama, man, there was
here, right? Let's leave it at that, tell me
later, tell me...
Bri sent a picture of YouTube
Premium, which he said changed his life,
and look, I feel sorry for him because
after I...  I subscribed to YouTube
Premium and my life has never been the
same since. So, I'm still
surviving... Lucas sent the "
abastece" (refuel) and said it helped
save some money. The namesake of this Lucas...
the other Lucas sent the "cling" (
cling), Kau sent one that you'll
like X
ingresso.com (that one has my fingerprints on it, there
must be a bug with my
subscription there to this day).
And Pilon and Neui... oh, there's a double app
today, double referral, they talked about Extrava, it's a little
clunky). So that's it, I think that's it,
keep sending them to us, ask for the
last one, I'll even look again here to
see if anyone else sent one since we
sent the 40 at the last minute as always,
as always. Another thing
we always say we're going to do
but never do is at the beginning of the program
ask people to go there and interact, right?
Go there, interact with our posts
when we publish the program,
comment, comment on Spotify, comment on
Subtitles, comment on YouTube, all of that helps a lot for
the platforms to understand
that you're enjoying the program and to
recommend it to...  So, leave
your comment, Zinho, your like, your five
stars, add it to the playlist, follow if
you don't already, help us out,
and recommend it, because if each person
who listens to this program brings in one more
listener, we double in size, isn't that how
math works? That's it,
PR specialist talking about
comments and things like that, I wanted to
send a shout-out to Marina
Fernandes, she always sends us the
app of the week, this week she didn't send one,
but she always does. But she
commented, she even commented on
the last episodes, saying that, man, we
talked about it,
she sent Nmade and Wise in the last episode, and
in the previous episode she also commented here
that
her favorite episode is Episode 39, which
you said was yours too. Look, we're
together Marina, Marina, we're seeing,
we said we were going to pick a
comment from the last edition to read in this one, we
picked it here, and next week it
could be yours, just go there and leave a
comment for us on any
platform, we read it here, it's
[Music] that's it,
and with that we end
today's program, with that we
end, man.  And we'll be back next week! That's
it! In addition to the announcements already
made, follow us on social media
@produces